I woke up today I didn't sleep good last
night why I just couldn't I have to
sleep up oh no and the um and so this
morning I wake up and
Avery T me he goes see you tonight at
8:20 okay to do a show M but I'm about
to lie and see that I'm sick just say
it's MLK Day oh it is what do you mean
it is you don't know that every day is
MLK day for me good got him got him got
every day I every day my favorite leader
yeah I I debated coming here to his
podcast I know should I call Avery and
then lie on the phone you've done this
once before I I know because you don't
think he's going to watch this episode I
know but this is later okay not airing
today right what are you say so in two
weeks from now he's going to be like you
lying I go yeah I'll see you at 8:5 so
what are you going to say to him wait
did you already like commit to it
previously though then it's just poor
work ethic on your part yeah
exactly Bingo nailed it that's it no but
I'm uh but I'm also so tired that now
I'm thinking because now cuz we have a
podcast later too and then I'm like I
have to squeeze in a nap well then just
say that don't have to say you're sick
I'm over just be like yeah I'm tired I
don't have it in me or can I call him
and do it now or no yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think you maybe try the live the let
me let me reverse it let me reverse it
okay hey Avery hey what's up man oh
thank you you're playing him right yeah
okay you still you still yeah sorry let
me well can I start yeah hey every hey
man what's going on sorry my house is
caught on fire I could really use you on
the show tonight because you really
bumped ticket sales and God I could
really use the extra money right now how
are you I'll be
there I hope he doesn't do that no I
hope he doesn't you want to do realistic
you want to do realistic yeah yeah yeah
okay cool oh yeah so hey what's
up no realistic hey what's up Bobby hey
dude oh bro I just found I remember you
the show tonight and I'm just you know
I'm so I'm overworked are you oh you are
man I I'm just I'm exhausted I'm over
work I just don't think I can make it
I'm sorry to hear that but um okay you
know who wouldn't cancel Sebastian
Maniscalco cuz he's [__] doing the
show here's the thing who's on the show
and and that'll help here's the thing
because Avery what Avery because when
you're the biggest person on the show
Bobby you are helping sell a lot of
tickets so so people are going tonight
being like I can't wait to see Bobby Lee
meanwhile you're gonna be balls deep in
a flashlight being like I'm TI
taii what ti Tai tired balls deep in a
flashlight Bobby okay so tonight so
tonight check it out okay tonight's this
reading and paying attention to to yeah
today's lineup is this we have um Mark
Maron great oh wow oh yeah Elijah
Schlesinger
crushing and my favorite the kid them oh
jrman yeahman so they already have an
Asian why did you oh J Guzman they
already have an asent the and he's
cleaner and he's got more um Dynamic um
things he can do text him half your set
and be like hey Bobby can't make it
tonight here's his
portion with a guitar can I do it or no
um how do you feel how do you really
feel here's what you you could leave him
on his toes and be like I might make it
I might not I mean I can make it but
I'll be super tired and grumpy yeah and
it's here's another thing that I found
out that whenever I do Spa I just don't
sleep that night because it's like I
have I drink a lot of Diet Cokes to get
my energy up to perform and then by the
time it's like 3: in the morning I'm
still up what do you have tomorrow is it
tomorrow sleep in day or you
busy sounds like a sleeping
day yeah have
nothing you're right right see in my
head I would just power through it
tonight and sleep in tomorrow but it is
it is funny but it's funnier to cancel
on the phone just try it or you could
just give my heads up like I might be
there I might not depending on how I'm
feeling after recording and Avery's a
great guy he books me a lot for show
he's great great
guy you think they know instinctually
Bobby's calling me he never calls
me okay he's going to call me back when
he calls me I'll pick up yeah anyway
you've never probably working his like
fourth shift of the day to
try to pay for the show but no it's fine
yeah just to book your booking fee alone
what is it these days 9,000 no no no do
you ever cancel I try not to but very
you do but but the same way I'm in a
[__] mood and I get that but it's
always the shows I don't want to do that
I have the most fun on cuz you're you're
mad you're angry then you get that first
like wave of laughter and you're like oh
I love this right I mean but you do feel
guilty when you do you do I do but I I
generally won't like unless it's like a
real like I like over booked or [__]
up or something yeah Trevor have you
ever traveled to go see a girl for the
first time
no can I just say something he's and
she's referring to and I I just told the
story okay but it's a really I
understand but I changed I changed the
name places it's in New Foundland so
when we refer to it it's New Foundland
new found new new found New Foundland
but you know the story yes yes you told
me the story I know I did and have I
ever done that and been rejected and
been rejected well that was the alley
oop to your
question yeah
um
I I've driven to like Co Mesa before
that's bro from from Sherman Oaks to
Costa Mesa 2 and a half 3 hour
commitment far yeah that's far uh I've
never gotten did you get action I did
see there we go Oh I thought you said
scene like and cut cut no yeah yeah yeah
I did but um I oh here we hello he Bubby
who's this Avery oh thank God thank god
what happened I called you I love you I
I love you too I'm so sick oh man okay
how sick sick sick I can't even
move Define movement
what when I blink when I blink pain pain
I just blinked it pain so pain so much
pain and I'm congested and my uh I got
monkey you have a
monkey monkey you AIDS oh my god oh
monkey pox okay that's
okay so you don't you don't want to do
it eh well I just if you want me to get
everyone's
sick I don't know what happens when you
don't come do people get angry what what
do what do I tell them well I mean you
have a great lineup you have Mark [__]
you have singer you have JB smoth what
not J Guzman yeah he he can't either he
said he had to he had to cancel but wait
wait gozman had to cancel there's no
Asians yeah there's no Asians on the
lineup now yeah that's what I'm saying
you you know why why did go why why did
he [__] cancel he heard you were on
the line no no why did he do it why did
he why did he do it uh he's he's sick as
well well you know so there we go he's
younger too so you know we may have the
same thing we have an Asian thing is it
is it going around it's a monkey pox
Asian thing yeah yeah it's a monkey po
Only Hits Asians Dr to Dr K Dr K Dr K
can't even talk right now don't can't
get talk oh my God so sorry well it
started with you know what Ali Ali Wan
queed and then we all got it yeah I can
see I can imagine that she has an angry
queef it spreads you know me yeah yeah
you know some cuddlefish they like spray
their eggs in the ocean and the and then
the current will spread the [__] you
know eggs all over the Pacific and stuff
that's what Ali ons queef air does with
Mony pox anyway my point is that
goodbye it's not happening you're not
coming now I'm GNA let me see if I how
about this let me just see okay okay I
will love you a long time if you want to
like literally come in the side door I
will let you in put you on stage and
then you can leave if you want okay I I
I'll call you later I love you I love
you bye think of me the fact that he's
so sweet so you have to do it man I feel
like you if anybody you should call JR
De Guzman and be like what the [__] yeah
he also did say I love you long time
which is pretty racist it it's it's up
there he's pandering he said I love you
long time which kind of pissed me off so
I think that's another so maybe you go
there and then right as you about to go
on stage you go I don't want to go up
and then you walk out you think so no
it's [__] I'll take any suggestion
what what podcast you have after this
ours what this one two No guest no we do
I I know but what guest because that
depends like if they oh this is energy
soccer rck GL GL energy socer you got to
be on you got to be on I want to be off
I don't want to do it uh oh he's in you
know he's coming here's what you do you
get Jared Guzman to do your role on the
next podcast you do the store come back
Diet Coke up the ass we're
in okay okay okay okay is that how you
get your energy Diet Cokes I get I drink
sugarfree Red Bulls and some die Cooks
what you don't do anything coffee yeah
yeah Celsius those are good yeah but you
when you asked him about him traveling
to coost of Meson and stuff yes I also
know that can I just also and you're
single still right mm yeah I also know
the level he's at I'm sorry yeah but
like I know I'm sorry